good morning
Sun didn't even rise and I'm always
sweating
3am and go to sleep around 8pm
good morning
[Music]
first thing I try not to do in the
morning is to go on my phone it's harder
during summer breaks because we have
more time to wait and less structure to
our day but it's also more rewarding
because now we can invest that time into
personal growth do things we actually
enjoy
so good now let's have our first
breakfast of the day
I'd like to priorities how it's planning
my day even during free periods with no
school or work because if I don't it's
so easy to spend the whole day in my
pajamas just being on social media or
binge watch a Netflix show that I don't
even care much about so now I'll plan my
day with fun stuff that I want to do but
also with stuff that I need to get done
for my final year of medical school and
with some job related work as well
foreign
[Music]
didn't even rise and I'm always sweating
so much and it's not even as like a 10
minute walk ah today is gonna be a rough
it's so pretty I'm so happy I'm here
[Music]
thank you
I love fighting places when it's early
in the morning because you get to see
the sunrise and there's not as mentors
around and it's just so peaceful but I
don't go out as soon as I wake up
because it's New York I don't want to
get kidnapped
[Music]
oh look at this View
I've been just relieving my goals for
the summer and been reflecting on what
I've been doing well and where I could
improve on to achieve those goals so I
can adjust my strategy and have almost
no regrets after my summer break
finishes so I'll tell you some of them
hopefully you can get some ideas and
inspiration for yourself firstly like
most people I need to earn and save some
money for next year because in the UK we
get very little loan from student
finance for our final year of medical
school second spending more time with
family and friends exercising more in
nature and finally focusing more on my
mental health
[Music]
let's get our second breakfast of the
day I'm starving
they're open in six minutes so I'm gonna
wait around oh wait someone just went in
I think
could I order it now can I get a chive
cream cheese with roasted tomatoes
please with everything bagel toasted I
just wanted one yeah thank you
yes please
foreign
there was this couple taking their
wedding pictures in front of the bridge
that's so cute
anyway
I'm going inside
I've got food the aircon is on life is
perfect
one of my main goals this summer is
prioritizing my mental health during the
busy Academic Year it's so easy to
sacrifice activities that supports my
well-being to save more time to study
and for other responsibility like early
mornings are my favorite time of the day
and I love going for a little morning
walk but I've been replacing that with
the revision but I'm trying to balance
both and I want to be well rested both
physically and mentally before I start
next year if you have similar goals you
might find today's paid partnership with
better help helpful they're a
professional therapist service that is
completely online and to have a diverse
network of therapists with expertise in
various areas at the start you answer a
few questions to get a personalized
match with a therapist that suits your
needs for me I wanted support from
immersion point of view but also someone
who can guide me and challenge me with
my goals and if your therapist is not
right for any reason which can happen
when your first start therapy we can
switch to a new one with no costs
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just a human living in this
world going through a hard time if we
can teach you tools to approach life in
a very different way so I would really
recommend better help if you've been
struggling to connect with a therapist
and you can get 10 of your first month
at betterhelp.com
[Music]
I'm going to meet friends later on so I
want to finish all my work beforehand so
I can be stress-free afterwards I need
to email hospitals in other countries
and convince them to take me in because
in the UK we have something called
medical elective where we're required to
do a clinical placement away from our
own medical school for about six weeks
so even though it's summer I still have
some preparations to make for my final
year of medical school
[Music]
foreign
my childhood friend of over 12 years so
I'm going to ask her what she thinks of
my sleep schedule first of all it's been
like this since forever there's nothing
new it's not like med school thing it's
very health personality I remember when
you used to sleep over in my house in
the morning when I wake up you would be
awesome I had my second breakfast I
watched two movies in the middle of the
day you've done everything you need to
do and I'm just starting even when we're
in the same country still in different
times time zones yeah sometimes you need
to sacrifice I think we do that a lot
when we want to hang out swear to God
I'm more in the same time zone with my
grandma in Turkey
please don't let this 4 a.m morning
routine to influence you without any
context during the year I naturally wake
up around 3am and go to sleep around 8pm
but in summer I want to stay out later
and socialize more everyone's lifestyle
and priorities are different and our
Natural Body clock is a whole Spectrum
saying that though I feel like we've
designed this world in favor of morning
people most schools and jobs start early
in the morning summer breaks gives us a
rare opportunity where we can encourage
our own sleep schedule with hopefully
less pressure from our society